on the next episode of AMC's The Walking
Dead it worked
time to give up there's no more supplies
going in but there might be people we
have to be ready get the guns and get
away onto it
all you need to do is survive tonight
hey everybody we have the midseason
finale of The Walking Dead next week so
let's break it down we also needed to
talk about the fear The Walking Dead
crossover because they just confirmed
some details about that especially which
character we're going to see pop up on
that show and if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get
everything I do giveaway stuff every
week then I'll explain at the end of the
video things are finally coming to a
head and it looks like they're not going
to be benching anybody this time if you
remember in the season opener you had
everybody from the safe zone going
against negan but there were still a
bunch of them like Rosita that stayed
home and now you have a situation
whereby Rick is able to secure the help
of a scavengers which we all predicted a
long time ago they flip-flop so many
times that it wasn't gonna be that hard
for Rick to win them back over but at
the same time you have that rogue
splinter group from the safe zone that
just completely went off the rails like
I can imagine when Rick comes back to
the safe zone he's gonna be like you had
one job to do and now everything has
been set on fire the plan has been
destroyed so you can kind of see the
logic and the riders doing this they
want to take away all these crazy
advantages that rick's group had and
they want to make it seem like it's
gonna be insurmountable and I know like
everybody's wondering about this big
Eugene twist because he spent so much of
last week's episode just talking in
talking and talking nee it'll likely
execute me is what he considers to be a
personal favor or I could go for what's
behind door number 2 take my chances
being shot in the back by some time ally
despite any injury I may have caused in
the past delivering a chomp down on your
children and usually after a couple
minutes of Eugene nonsense talk you kind
of tune out a little bit because even
though he's trying to say that he's
gonna do whatever it takes to survive
you get that with that first
conversation when they're on the rooftop
but then he goes in and he talks to
Father Gabriel and it's almost like a
version of the confessional that they
had inside the trailer when he was stuck
in there with negan like he's sort of
confessing to him that I'm willing to do
whatever it's going to take and you can
even see the look on Gabriel's face Lord
take this dumbass away they danced
around him giving Dwight up to negan so
I think that they're gonna maintain that
advantage that's the one thing that
Rick's
has going for them inside the sanctuary
so let me know in the comments do you
actually think that they're going to
kill Eugene during the mid-season finale
because usually big episodes like that
demand to sacrifice or multiple
sacrifices so I feel like Rosita is
probably also expendable like she is
ready to give up her life and because
Tara is an LGBTQ character and it's not
really in vogue to kill those types of
characters she might wind up crawling
away and even though daryl has gone
completely off the rails I think a long
time ago Robert Kirkman joked to him
that he was never going to die but he's
just so popular on the TV show that I'm
not expecting them to kill him anytime
soon same thing with Michonne you saw
her in the flash-forward so you already
know that she survives to whatever that
time period is that seems like it's much
much further on than the end of the
season because you have Rick with the
giant gray beard but they've been
playing it fast and loose with those
flash-forwards so some of it's a dream
sequence some of it seems like it
actually might come to pass like the
whole idea is is that there's gonna be
some compromise like they're not just
gonna mow each other down the Savior's
in the safe zone they'll find a way to
resolve it's this relatively similar to
comic book all-out war if you actually
want to read the end of that you can
totally do that because I think they're
gonna do at least some of the big twist
from it even if some of the characters
are different so if you have read that
and you want to talk about the comic
book storyline just please use spoiler
tags in case people haven't read it yet
there's still a lot of people that
haven't read the comics but one of the
biggest examples of changes that they've
made to the comic book storyline is
Jadis is scavenger group there is
another group that they might introduce
from the comics but using what happened
to sheba as a benchmark it does seem
like they're going to end the mid-season
finale
with the end of all-out war part 1 and
just do all-out war part 2 during the
second half of the season so if you do
want to read ahead between seasons just
start with issue number one 21 that's
the beginning of all-out war while you -
it goes to issue 126 so it's actually
not that long but there's still a couple
of other hanging plot threads that need
to wrap up you have Gregory at Hilltop
Maggie just sort of threw him in with
the Savior's so they need to take care
of him
hopefully they'll resolve that
relatively quickly because she's been
the de facto leader for a while now and
he's really just a vestige of that
previous storyline
like he's not going to be helping anyone
anytime soon but I think the whole idea
is is that my mercy prevails all these
saviors here might be able to integrate
with the group if given the chance
because that was the whole idea with
Eugene at the end of last week's episode
as much of a dirt bag as he was he was
actually trying to save all those
workers who didn't have a whole lot to
do with negan's army like obviously
every savior is a potential person in
Egan's army but the whole idea is is
that they're growing dissatisfied with
negan so all it takes is like a really
big push to revolt against him and
that's where Dwight comes in he's trying
to minimize the amount of casualties but
because of what the dumb-ass brigade did
at the end of the last episode they just
want to make you feel like that's almost
impossible the last big question let me
know what you think of the last couple
of episodes of The Walking Dead and for
those of you asking about Walking Dead
videos I haven't completely stopped
doing them just because the quality is
dropped I've just started doing them for
every couple of episodes so of course
I'm doing a regular video for the
mid-season finale episode but then also
when we come back at the beginning of
the year with episode 9 I'll do a video
for that and then just take the
temperature and do more episode videos
on a weekly basis depending on interest
level but getting into the fear The
Walking Dead crossover they officially
confirmed that Morgan was going to be
the crossover they haven't completely
revealed what the story is or how that's
going to work logistically whether it
was going to be in present day and fear
The Walking Dead is just gonna catch up
to where they are on the timeline or if
it's going to be a flashback sequence
but I think because Morgan has gone so
off the rails lately that he'll try to
recenter himself by leaving the group
and going off on his own and that's how
he'll wind up with a fear of The Walking
Dead people like I just need to get out
of here and he winds up running into
them but I know about everybody's
theories that there might be an origin
story for the whisperers and they'll
introduce them in a later season I do
think that they'll push the whisperers
off to a future season just because it's
such a big story arc in the comics and
they're still in the thick of all-out
war right now whispers is like a thing
that you do after you do the negan
storyline so no spoilers for whispers
but that's just ways down the road in
there is a new round of that walking
dead giveaway we'll see therefore I max
gift certificates just because it's
movie season right now so all you have
to do to enter that is be a subscriber
and
comment on the video congratulations to
the winner from the last video Juan
Ocampo please private message me so I
can get your contact details you can
click here for my new infinity war hulk
video and you can click here for all my
other Walking Dead videos thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight